the origins and development of Halloween
can be pretty confusing but it is a
really fascinating story that can tell
us a lot about how these kinds of
traditions and holidays um develop and
how religions and cultures interact
throughout history in different ways to
create some of the most famous and
popular festivals of the year in this
case most people trace the origins of
Halloween to an ancient Celtic quote
unquote Pagan festival called
sawin and while this theory is most
likely true the history of the festival
is also much more complicated than that
Sinn was the Celtic New Year an annual
Festival that marked the end of the
summer season and inaugurated the coming
winter it's a transitionary moment in
the calendar in other words and was
accompanied by various celebrations